[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
very excited to be talking about heart
and brain diseases and how we can in
advance understand the pathologies
happening - our body live longer and
healthier we have dr. Carew Nia condi
mala joining us on the show hello hello
thank you for coming on really
appreciate it yes such an pleasure thank
you to Kishore for introducing us
your cousin yes and you also have your
daughter visiting as well into the Bay
Area and it's knife she's visiting
Berkeley yes yes and your background is
very cool you've been an associate
professor in the Department of fart at
pharmaceutics at the University of
Minnesota for the last seven years also
a research collaborator at Mayo Clinic
you were previously also visiting
scientists and an adjunct professor in
the Department of Neurology at Mayo
Clinic and you've been now focusing on
macro molecular pharmacokinetics related
to Alzheimer's disease and metabolic
syndrome and developing nanotech for
diagnosis and treatment of
cerebrovascular disease so this is very
important for us to understand this
affects one out of every six of us by
the age of 65 one out of every two of us
by the age of eighty mm-hmm so this is a
big deal for us to be able to have you
were teaching earlier about the
preventative steps that we can take in
order to prevent the aunts the onset of
neurodegenerative diseases so Caronia
let's start off on a on us on a big
history perspective you know we find
ourselves as stewards of Earth we have 8
billion of us now there's exponential
technology happening we have so much
great science that can help us what's
your current take on this state of you
you know I have a very optimistic
perspective I think Humanity is
progressing then actually moving the
frontiers in science as well as in
technology previously people only used
to live up to 50 to 60 years of age but
now we expect it to live it so 80 so
that's a that's a real possibility with
those advances also come challenges so
because Alzheimer's is one of the
diseases of Aging so if a person is
about 70 there is a 15% chance but above
80 there is almost a 50% chance of
getting Alzheimer's so you know those
challenges could be also consequences of
the progress we have been making but at
the same time the science is evolving at
a rate and and to a level where
humanities is probably getting ready to
face these challenges and solve them
eventually yes yes and the relationship
between the heart and the brain to what
affects the heart as something that is
bad is very much so associated with
affecting the brain as something is bad
and that's something that you found with
type 2 diabetes and now we'll continue
you know talking about through this
conversation these are the two of those
central organs to our you know existence
and our health so caronia you're right
the the scientific frontier is pushing
us in the direction of being able to
solve these tough challenges we're very
excited for that what has been your
journey to get to the point of your
fascination in your interest with
solving these challenges
I think it's the fascination to deal
with the unknown so I have a natural
tendency to gravitating towards what is
unknown and what's more challenging so
as a consequence I get myself in trouble
every now and then and I still remember
one of my professors when I was doing my
doctoral study at the University of
man's universe of Iowa he commented you
know looking at my project which is to
investigate how drugs permeate from nose
to brain so like say for example drugs
of abuse and drug and therapeutic
molecules also could permeate once
they're in the nasal cavity into brain
so they pathways that they take to reach
the brain are poorly understood so my
PhD thesis was investigating what those
pathways are and how body can protect
itself from being bombarded by these
molecules you know if it's drug then
it's beneficial but it could be toxin to
for example manganese aluminum all those
metals could get into brain 3 inhalation
viruses could get into brain via the
nasal pathway so we were my thesis was
to investigate that and the professor
was used to ask me like so how long do
you want to stay here you know it's is
it a 10-year project or is there a
five-year project so it was risky but
that's what was the driving force
likewise when I moved to being a faculty
member again I started looking into the
pathophysiology of Alzheimer's
instead of threading the known or well
investigated path I started a different
direction which I felt is probably what
might be the earliest risk to neuro
degeneration which is insults to the
vasculature
to the blood vessels if in the brain
blood vessels they you know the brain is
is heavily perfused which means there is
almost a small blood vessel for every
neuron in the brain because neurons need
nourishment and they generate a lot of
byproducts that should be cleared from
the brain and vasculature the blood
vessels can do that very well so
whatever so for every neuron open every
neuron that's how dense the blood
vessels are in the brain because brain
needs a lot of energy which is supplied
in the form of glucose so to that supply
is is consistently maintained by the
blood vessels the blood vessels are
bringing the glucose into brain into the
brain right yes and then the so we have
almost a hundred billion plus of these
little micro blood vessels micro
vasculature that brings the glucose up
that powers the brain and it brings
oxygen alright oxygen which is very
critical so unless the blood vessels are
functioning very well
it's it's hard for the brain to to get
that nourishment and also a lot of
byproducts are generated a lot of
metabolites if they start accumulating
in the brain it's very hard to maintain
the what we call homeostasis which is
the balance in the brain so blood
vessels again to move all those break
breakdown products into the bloodstream
so that they could be eliminated
so this should be this should be
functioning very very effectively for
proper brain physiology yes yes so then
simultaneously as the as our blood is
bringing up the glucose and oxygen it's
bringing a down the the build up
developed yeah okay
the toxic product oxic and this is fat
cholesterol and then amyloid proteins
riled up right mmm elide protein is also
regarded as one of those byproducts of
brain metabolism so we don't know what
the function is but we do know that it
is then and every every brain amyloid
protein is there in every brain but in
Alzheimer's brain it is over produced
because the blood vessels or the brain
itself is not able to clear them so they
start accumulating and cause problems
one of the problems they could cause is
they is killing the neurons yes yes okay
so for for you how did it come up for
you the moment for for I want to be
focused on this specifically yeah again
while I was doing my doctoral work one
of the reasons we were investigating you
know the purpose of investigating nose
to brain delivery of molecules yes is to
look at resolving the issues associated
with Alzheimer's because in Alzheimer's
disease the one of the first brain areas
that are affected is the olfactory
senses or factory system interesting for
our nose right yeah for us being able to
process what we smell are able to smell
basically so and Alzheimer's patient why
you know why
we don't know why but we could see some
connections and sort of guests
associations at this point so olfactory
system is the only part of the central
nervous system that's exposed to the
environment this right is the only what
about taste is not because that's it is
not directly the part of the central
nervous system hey Susan yeah you you
have the neurons of course supplying you
know the nerves that are supplied to the
tongue for the taste perception yes but
it is not directly directly exposed part
of the central nervous system no we have
only nerves being supplied to all over
the water but in the olfactory system
the olfactory neurons are actually
exposed to the environment and that's
right up here right up right so the nose
of the nose and then okay interesting
okay so the also also you can actually
trace the area the olfactory processing
part of the brain whom all the way to
you can trace the roof of the nasal
cavity to the roof of the nasal cavity
where the olfactory epithelium is is
located interesting yeah these these
senses that we have to process our
environments are very very interesting
science irritations and how we building
new senses is very much for staying yeah
yeah okay now now take us to the you
know your your teachers you actually
started you know hinting at what this
this what what is if the if the blood
vessels themselves have issues with
bringing up the the glucose and bringing
up the oxygen that that process can
start deteriorating and actually you
were teaching me earlier and this is an
important point to teach that it's 90 no
that's a hundred percent there's a
hundred percent failure rate in clinical
trials for Alzheimer's disease and
that's because we're not we're not doing
it early right
enough right yeah so most of the
therapies that went into phase 3
clinical trials you know I'm talking
about the novel treatments of
Alzheimer's
there are conventional treatments to
actually those we call coalesced race
inhibitors that are available on the
market but it's they deal with sort of
temporary effects caused by Alzheimer's
disease but they don't address the root
cause but one of the attempts that were
made to address the root cause is to is
to therapeutically remove the toxic
amyloid proteins that accumulate in
Alzheimer's brain so and that removal is
done by antibodies against the amyloid
beta proteins so many of those
antibodies went into clinical trials but
faced but failed in phase 3 clinical
trials the antibodies are trying to go
and remove the amyloid protein buildup
right and that you were doing it too
late in the process you know that is the
that is sort of the reasoning that
scientists are coming up were they to
explain the failure of those clinical
trials but there could be several
aspects associated with it
one is amyloid accumulation could be a
consequence of some
pathological damage that really caused
problems yes so it could be a bystander
but genetic data clearly shows that
amyloid is a critical part of the
Alzheimer's pathology so it's a you know
there could be a sort of a shift in the
role of amyloid proteins very early on
in the disease and then compared to that
in later portions so unless we know and
understand what that shift is it's very
hard to time when the therapy should be
administered yes yes and let's pull up
our images that help us explain what
we're talking about okay yes so this is
these are the stats you were mentioning
earlier affecting one in every six
people above seventy years and one out
of every two people above 80 years now
interesting first patient diagnosed by
dr. a Louis Alzheimer Alzheimer a
hundred years ago the 1920s right
interesting and do you know the story of
how a Louis Alzheimer how did how did
is this a he this is she she's used to
complain she she uh is the is the
professor or is the doctor no doctor is
Alzheimer oh but is the doctor he or
Acosta is she doctor is he agus - is she
okay and yeah and howhow did she and he
how did how did Louis understand August
ace issue how did he it works open her
to understand me yeah so he provided the
first clinical documentation of the
cognitive loss in Alzheimer's patient so
she used to complain confusion memory
loss all the classical changes that we
are seeing now in Alzheimer's patients
then dr. Alzheimer went beyond just the
clinical investigation he in fact looked
at the autopsy brain of
door interesting and then he noticed
those plaques in the brain hundred years
ago Wow
and later on since the past thirty years
scientists all over the world have been
investigating what those flags are made
of and then how are they causing how are
they associated with the Alzheimer's
pathophysiology so we have identified
now that those plaques are made of
amyloid beta proteins and those a beta
proteins they are the aggregate very
rapidly and those aggregates the small
aggregates could actually could be very
toxic compared to amyloid beta protein
that's that's a that hasn't our grenaded
that stir that remains as a monomer what
we call just one molecule so that it's
not that toxic but when it starts
aggregating those aggregates can be very
very toxic and they can several
scientists have even compared them to be
prions again that have tendency to
aggregate and those prions cause mad cow
disease interesting so so this is an a
hundred years ago we're talking you know
at autopsy is what started our
scientific understanding of the memory
loss disease issues this is very
important because these are those this
is how you get to an edge of science is
that you have to take initiative and and
do things like do an autopsy and find
these these amyloid protein buildups and
this is the the plaque is specifically
the last 30 years he's saying we're
understand we're diving into
understanding the plaque that's building
up and causing the plaque causes the
neurons to die because and what's the
relationship with the tangles as well
yeah it might not be the plaque that's
problematic it might be those Anagha
Murs before plaque formation that are
distributed all over the brain that
could be causing the problem
plaque according to many scientists
could be a protective mechanism so
body is actually encapsulating those
proteins into a plaque and which is then
not that toxic because so the plaque
formation could be a protective
mechanism similar to like formation of a
thrush lauric plaque in the blood
vessels that could be a protective
mechanism but when it's and it grows
bigger it blocks the blood vessels and
cause problems yes yes so it's you know
as in day and these cardiovascular
diseases instead of actually removing
the plaque we tend to address issues
that promote the generation of the
plaque but in case of Alzheimer's we
might be doing it in a different way
where D we are trying to deal with the
plaque formation and trying to clear or
break that plaque down rather than
addressing the issues that have caused
the problem yes that have caused the
plaques yes so according to you know our
investigations the cerebral vascular
damage could be one of the contributing
factors to that eventual buildup of
plaques on the brain
yes the the healthier these billions of
microvasculature that's carrying the
glucose and oxygen up the healthier that
that is the less of the plaque buildup
that even occurs in the first place oh
so this is again this is this is coming
to you know preventive medicine that the
healthcare your you were wearing and how
do we then keep the the billions of
microvasculature healthy - what's our
what's our strategy yeah we've known
this foot all along right you know it's
right exercise and right amount of
exercise and food yeah so sleep what you
do yeah yes silly back you know they
didn't there was a study published in
science that demonstrated sleeplessness
can promote amyloid buildup in the brain
so again suggesting that those are all
the healthy lifestyle is the key to to
protect protect the person from these
neurodegenerative diseases yes yes yes
Ronnie let's go to that next image -
okay and this is kind of you know as
we're talking but you mentioned earlier
this the fact that you know we typically
don't think of one little micro
vasculature with blood vessels for every
single neuron in the brain that's a very
interesting point so that's called this
blood-brain barrier isn't in that's
that's that's right you know that's
really starts right about at the at
where the the initial part of the brain
starts so usually all the blood vessels
that's kind of supplying blood to the
brain
they have endothelial membrane where the
endothelium is the cell lining of the
blood vessels okay so all the blood
vessels are lined by endothelial cells
okay a single layer of endothelial cells
difference between the brain blood
vessels and the blood vessels in the
periphery in other parts of the body is
that the endothelial cells in the brain
blood vessels are all sealed together
interesting so there there are no gaps
no they prevent the movement of any
molecules non-specifically to get into
brain they prevent the movement of
bacteria movement of viruses interest
any extraneous substances unwanted
substances from getting into brain
because brain cells they don't have
ability like the peripheral cells to
protect themselves
neurons are highly specialized they do
what they you know they do their
functions very very systematically and
with high fidelity so they don't have
the same capacity
to handle the abuses like the peripheral
cells and so they need protection they
need a certain environment to function
effectively all that is maintained by
other cells other supporting cells and
endothelium and the pineal cell is one
of the most critical supporting cells
fascinating endothelial cells are what
they're lined just very tightly in the
blood as it's going up to the brain
they're very tightly and that prevents
the bacteria and other things that the
body cells can fight against the brain
neuron cells cannot fight against
because they're super focused on
activity in the breast that the brain
has to do this is very interesting so
then in the body that and again
endothelial and so there are gaps there
gaps so that nutrients could go in and
out likewise the metabolites the toxic
substances could get out quite easily
but in the brain we don't have those
gaps as a consequence brain need
specialized systems to send material and
to send signals in and out of the brain
and then this called blood-brain barrier
is then because you can't send of like a
molecule through the blood up into the
brain unless brain wonka needs it
interesting so won't take molecules
unless it's unless the body already
considers it like an endogenous lee made
substance that then so you can kind of
trick right the blood the brain in today
they're taking it I say for example
glucose in a body is three percent
brain is three percent of body's weight
but then it consumes 15 percent of
glucose so I've heard that numbers as
high as 25 is that couldn't be it could
could be depending on the condition okay
but at a normal physiological level and
average it's about 15% so all for all
that glucose to get into brain
effectively the blood-brain barrier has
glucose transporters functioning again
with high fidelity you know that you
they cannot be any damage to those
glucose transporters otherwise the brain
could suffer from lack of nutrition and
this is where insulin is a big key I
would like to again make a distinction
there
those glucose transporters they don't
listen to anyone
they don't even listen to glucose
they're independent of glucose so the
glucose transporters and the periphery
in the body they respond to insulin they
need insulin to act for them to you know
actually insulin signals them to to take
up glucose yes those vehicles
transporters are insulin dependent like
in the muscle for example it is insulin
dependent uptake of glucose but in the
brain
it occurs independent of insulin because
interesting you know insulin goes up and
down in the body in a you know depending
on the time of the day depending on the
consumption of food insulin levels keep
going up and down if the glucose
transporters and the blood-brain barrier
is listening to insulin then there will
be a huge shift in the amount of insulin
getting into brain depending on the
condition so it's a very steady for the
brain it is very straight but the body
is much different in response but
interesting right so this functioning is
is actually regulated by blood-brain
barrier which is the endothelium then
there are other cells in the blood
vessels account parasites so parasites
are like supporting cells to the
endothelium and then we have that's
that's part of the vasculature we have
the endothelium and then the parasites
in the blood vessels
on the brain side we have astrocytes and
neurons so all those four cells they
function together so we call that a
neurovascular unit okay so neuro
vascular's unit communicates and then it
it actually coordinates all the
regulatory functions that are happening
between the periphery and the brain yeah
so any damage done to the neurovascular
unit could be problematic and we believe
that it could be the earliest damage
done to the brain in Alzheimer's brain
the for those four cells to be mice
communicate is community yeah okay
interesting
and then the CBF mm-hmm
means so so what what is depicted in
this figure is the response of the
connection between endothelium the
blood-brain barrier and the neuronal
response so we call this neurovascular
coupling so these are so interlinked
that here when the new neural neural
response is triggered you know it could
be triggered by many activities like
even opening eyes could trigger neuronal
response in the visual cortex and so
once that neuronal response is triggered
then the neurons present in that brain
region needs nourishment into oxygen and
then they generate byproducts they
should be removed very very quickly
interesting to accomplish that function
the blood vessels are dilated yeah in
that region interesting and then they
supply more blood carrying the nutrients
and also to bring the metabolites out so
that response is the is what we called
neurovascular response and that's
measured by change in the cerebral blood
flow then you have neural restaurant
response very quickly you could see
changes in the cerebral
so this is the main signal that's
captured on functional MRI to actually
relate to which part of the brain is
functional yes under certain
stimulations right so yes this should be
done very very predictably but in
diseases like Alzheimer's disease that
neurovascular coupling is disrupted yeah
interesting yes
okay so then let me see if I can do this
so then the the neurovascular coupling
when you're meditating do you close your
eyes and you decrease the amount of
blood and glucose that's flowing to your
visual cortex and so then the the the
the the visual processing part of your
brain that that the neuro vascular's are
there it narrows and and because it
doesn't need the the processing because
your eyes are closed but it might not
narrow but you know it stays under
addressed at rest in the fMRI you can
see that there's less blood that's
moving to that part of the brain mm-hmm
okay
and then once you kind of open your eyes
again you can see in that from right
that the more blood it flows therefore
the processing and then the and then the
in then in a in a in a brain where the
the when this the cell communication
isn't working as well then it's not as
us the ability for for the for the the
blood to move into that part of the
brain is it's miscommunicated yeah okay
it cannot meet the demands of the the
neurons so if it's happening over a
period of time then the neurons could
die off in that region interesting yeah
if the miscommunication happens for long
periods in time then that causes the
neurons to die okay okay cool let's
let's move on yeah this is a this is a
good way of explaining the normal versus
the Alzheimer brain yeah so so you have
the material transport and the signaling
going on or carried on by the
blood-brain barrier between periphery
and the brain so you have all that
communications very well laid out in the
normal brain but then in Alzheimer's
brain that communication system is all
disrupted as a consequence you could see
the you know like like you see in a you
know on a higher highway you could see
the build up you could see the traffic
that's slowing down and if that traffic
if those cars or amyloid proteins then
they get backed up and once the maloik
proteins are together and if the
concentration is growing in the brain
they could aggregate those aggregates
could cause problems in the neurons and
then eventually can lead to the neuronal
death yeah yeah this this this analogy
is very powerful for you know we're
talking about diseases of heart and
brain this is similarly affects our
heart as well as when you see the with
the build up versus this free-flowing
the the traffic analogy is very powerful
thank you
yeah it's a really good one and so we
want we want to keep our our heart
vasculature as well as our brain at
neurovascular we want to keep this
moving like very smooth traffic and then
these things of really powerful sleep
good news
could exercise these are the things that
keep the M we'd built up down right yeah
because because the physiological
response is is robust as a consequence
the build up will not happen in the
first place so once that already once it
started happening then it might be very
hard to clear and repair all the
mechanisms that are responsible for for
the smooth flow like what you're
referring to yes yes so so even when you
when you go back to the reason why many
of the Alzheimer's therapy therapies
might be failing yes the therapies that
are focused on getting rid of the
plaques might be failing could be due to
the fact that the traffic the build-up
could be corrected but then what caused
that buildup is still not addressed so
as a consequence the neurons might not
recover from the damage that has been
done a while ago and it's again very
important to notice that now we have
clinical tools to see if they are malloy
it is building up in the brain so we
could use PET imaging to investigate the
amyloid buildup in the brain and we
clearly know now that the build-up
starts twenty years before the cognitive
changes are evident Wow so for 20 years
before so like what damage is done
within that 20 years is not clearly
understood
so so build-up could be starting as
early as age 40 even real good could be
will be as young as that if there is
familial Alzheimer's disease it's much
earlier like you know usually the
subject could suffer from Alzheimer's
when he or she is about 50 if it's
familial where caused by mutations in
the genes but most of the disease is is
sporadic which means that we don't know
what the cause is wow this is this is a
very very important for all of those
that are you know that are listening
that are in their you know adolescent
years in their 20s and even in your 30s
like really you know experience life to
the fullest now as best as you can
because even if we're not even realizing
that the cognitive decline is is slowly
occurring it really it really is
building up even if we're not noticing
the the decline right yeah okay because
there could be things happening you know
but without any notice and then all of a
sudden there could be changes in
cognition by then it might be already
too late yeah yeah and we had we have
one more yeah we had the one more image
as well last one that we can pull up to
and this one's actually supposed to be a
video but we didn't get the video so you
can explain it as an image so what this
picture is showing is the movement of
this vesicles movement of whatever cell
whatever nourishment cell gets that is
trafficked from one part of the cell to
the other part right so that is how data
that is handled by what we call
microtubules okay so these are these
microtubules like each streak is like a
microtubule yeah
so microtubule is like a railroad track
it directs that movement from the center
of the cell to the edge of the cell so
we can consider this as the center and
then moving towards the edge of the edge
here yeah so in a normal cell that flows
very smoothly yes yes but when the cells
are exposed to amyloid beta proteins
then you could see that those railroad
tracks Wow
this is just crisscross yeah these are
way less the communication like you were
saying it looks like the communications
horrible liar like it's just being
messed up and the communication here is
like looking like smooth mm-hmm
we know what we can almost predict where
it's going here it's a disaster and so
then this is where you can see that
amyloid plaque build up these are these
are actually the blood-brain barrier and
the pineal cells and these are a few a
few of all right so these are supposed
to move proteins not only amyloid beta
proteins but also a lot of HDL proteins
yeah yeah a lot of the iron carrying
proteins like transferring insulin
interesting they should be moved from
the bloodstream into brain yes if that's
what is going on in the in the pineal
cell then they will never reach brain in
required proportions and those are all
growth factors neurons need them for for
good function iron HDL HDL and in an
even insulin and even insulin yeah
because insulin is a growth factor it
not only regulates insulin it also
regulates the mitogenic activity what
they call is cell growth cell division
all those are regulated by insulin yes
so that's the reason why an insulin
signaling is disrupted you could see the
cancer cells growing yeah in also
inverse it's the opposite problem
because there is problem with insulin
signaling the cells start
and and what other what other techniques
are you using along with your students
along with you know University Minnesota
and Mayo Clinic what techniques are
being used especially in the field of
nanotechnology to both understand the
the pathophysiology but also to then go
and do preventive because I'm the
nutrition and exercise and sleep is a
very common mantra that civilization
chance what in an in like an in in a
nanotech perspective what could you know
be done to you know at age 32 you know
to 42 to get us to that you know
homeostatic capacity of like a 15 year
old to keep us healthy so now the reason
why we started developing nanoparticles
for the treatment and diagnosis of
Alzheimer's disease and the and to look
at the build-up of those amyloid
proteins in the blood vessels is looking
at the and at the examples from nature
for example HDL particles HDL particles
are nanoparticles right so they they
take up they actually clear cholesterol
from various cells and then they carry
the cholesterol to liver so
nanoparticles are could have the ability
to interact with the endothelial surface
yes the blood brain value and they might
be able to alter some of these processes
interests they could signal a change
signal a change that's one thing and the
second aspect is nanoparticles could
carry contrast agent for MRI pet to show
us where the problem is in that end
so that we could detect the trouble
early on interesting yes yes and then if
you can detect where the problems are at
then you can then go and target those
specific gears I can fix them right in
the signaling this in young ages you
said in PET scans and okay interesting
so we are developing novel probes to see
if there is any problem with the
endothelial function can we spot that
early on so that we might be able to
repair the damage and you know here this
is where I would like to bring the
association between Alzheimer's disease
and type 2 diabetes yes yes right so
there is a clear epidemiological
evidence that these two diseases are
related but we don't know how they're
connected mechanistically so we know
that in the periphery in other tissues
type 2 diabetes could cause problems to
the endothelium could cause problems in
the endothelial cells but what it does
to the brain blood vessels is poorly
understood right so if the there is a
problem with insulin signaling you know
type 2 diabetes causes insulin
resistance if there is a problem with
insulin signaling in the brain blood
vessels all the functions are most of
the functions that we've been talking
about could get disrupted because
they're connected to insulin signaling
so if we managed to find how they are
pathologically connected the type 2
diabetes and Alzheimer's one big
advantage could be we might be able to
repurpose diabetes drugs to treat
Alzheimer's
at least very early on so that that's
one of the motivations behind our work
can we repurpose reuse those drugs yes
to treat the neuro degeneration yes yes
yes because is that is that because then
similarly to how a drug that is
assisting with the with with with with
issues with the cardio vasculature with
those heart disease areas and issues can
then also be used for similar processes
pacification similar process
so you know with the diabetes the same
problems again HDL lowering LDL increase
insulin resistance all those are very
very they cause problems to the
vasculature so using the same tools and
similar understanding we might be able
to look at neuro degeneration in a with
a different in a different perspective
yes yes because instead of just focusing
on what goes on in the brain it might be
important for us to look at the aspects
that could directly interfere with them
the reign function and you know nowadays
the National Institutes of Health is has
been investing resources into
investigating the cerebral vascular
contributions to Alzheimer's disease but
still the field is in its infancy and
more work needs to be done in the other
direction yes more funding for the
National Institute of Health and for the
National Institute of nutrition we're
aiming to just set up a shout-out to dr.
Joon Yoon and in that process because
the it's very interesting that you bring
up this the connection between the heart
and brain disease and how if we
understand their connection better we
can tackle them together better this is
very important
Kearney this has been such an
interesting conversation together and
I'm really grateful that we ended up
sitting down with you on the show well
it's a pleasure
yeah thank you so much and we have a
couple questions that we like asking at
the end of our episode one of the
questions that we like asking is if you
think we are alone in the cosmos
[Music]
of course we are we are not and we have
known that but assuming that there are
people like ourselves is probably
far-fetched but I don't think we are
alone in the cosmos there might be
living beings elsewhere in the galaxies
but what they are how they are is
probably a frontier that has been
untouched yes yes yes and then the
second question we like to ask is if you
think we are in a simulation absolutely
you know
we don't I believe that we are in a
simulation but then is someone else
doing it or are we doing it to ourselves
you know in the sense are we forced to
act in a very particular way are we have
we programmed ourselves to do certain
things whether we like it or not
do we have real independence over our
thinking
so all those really you know makes me
believe that we could be in a simulation
but that could be self-inflicted it
might not be someone else really playing
with us or might be who knows right you
know I am I'm open to you know after
looking at this many unknowns I'm so
open to considering ideas that I'm not
aware of currently healthiest so but you
know whichever way it will be
fascinating to know yes correct
Oh high level of open-mindedness and
poking with science and the truth yes
yes and then the last question we like
to ask is what do you thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world
human mind I believe is the most
beautiful thing I might be biased but
the mere thought of try our the
motivation to know
actually is what convinces me that it's
the most beautiful thing and that's one
of the reasons why I focus on
Alzheimer's research because at the end
of life a person you know what is the
accumulating he or she not well not you
know fame name all those things are very
ephemeral but for that person what
really matters are the memories or the
feelings or the connections but in this
disease it's such a devastating disease
that all those are lost and to me that's
the real loss so that's the reason
that's that's that's what motivates me
to really find out if we could do
something about it
it's crazy how well these devices keep
the memory almost a hundred percent
efficiency but our brain doesn't keep
with that efficiency and on our deathbed
we are typically only remembering just
very sparse life events but if we can be
able to remember all of these
experiences feelings and memories that
we had and be able to store it for
children to be able to access in the
future and understand this is a very
interesting well what's wrong what if
what about the memories that we don't
want to remember
you know if t this is you know we this
brain has a self-protection mechanism
there's a lot you can't do about the
trauma you experienced yes you know you
know we don't want to remember because
it's causing pain but whatever causes
pain might not be not everything is bad
for example there are a lot of painful
memories that humanity has gone through
yeah if we forget them then we keep
repeating we keep getting into those
that's very painful things so memory
whether it's good or bad to a person or
to a community to society is a valuable
resource and that's all we have it
because I could bring up the murder rate
though you know if we remember these
dark experiences and we continuously
remember them and then you know oh I've
been through this [ __ ] before and
nothing happens nothing gets done and
then our self protective mechanism goes
into effect again and we use violent
measures to make sure that these
memories don't happen again we we have
had several guests like you know Coco
McKenzie and other people that have said
that on the other side of the traumas
are sometimes the greatest treasures and
it's very important to actually
integrate the learning experiences into
the
into the code of ourselves in the
civilization in total yeah even if the
microcosm you know now it is I believe
that because we we mentor graduate
students and that's our legacy and those
that are you know graduate students will
carry through their learning the
collective memory of our experience and
of our of our work
so nowadays I feel that they should be
more trained to handle bad memories
failures because if they're handled well
that could be such as lurking underneath
yes yes yeah and this is a whole nother
conversation on on on how to best be
able to integrate these traumas you know
maps and other the psychedelic studies
we've been experimenting with there's
been lots of interesting ways to to
integrate and did we get any questions I
see on YouTube we yes Charlie Sportello
watching in Akron Ohio asks if there's
any connection between aluminum foil and
Alzheimer's disease yeah excellent
question Charlie I think about 15 20
years ago
it was believed that magnesium aluminum
all those metals getting into brain
could cause Alzheimer's and they'd been
several studies looking at the role of
metals in how amyloid proteins aggregate
in fact amyloid beta aggregates in the
presence of metals but aluminum per se
has been ruled out as as the prime cause
but metals do play a role particularly
copper and zinc but then a metal key
later that can get rid of the metals
from the brain also failed in the
clinical trials so that might not be the
only reason
but we cannot totally rule
the role of metals in neurodegeneration
but aluminum foil is is probably you
know is very safe because it's the
aluminum that gets into that's inhaled
or that somehow can bypass the
blood-brain barrier and gets into brain
this could be problematic and but that
has also been ruled out as a major
casting um was that but now that was it
great Charlotte thank you Charlie yeah
it's nice everyone for tuning in that if
we do have questions if you feel free to
ask the questions in there in the
youtube and facebook chats and we'll ask
our guests the questions live on onset
Karenia thank you so much for coming
onto the show this has been such a
pleasure yeah thanks for having thank
you for teaching us about heart and
brain disease and about Alzheimer's
disease and about how we can really
start tackling this at a greater level
we really want to thank everyone for
tuning in thank you so much let us know
your thoughts in the comments below on
what we were discussing going to share
more with your communities your families
your friends on the internet get more
people talking about this and really
pushing the frontier of science in these
domains let's do it together everyone
inspire young people to get more
involved huge shout out to Ron Vargas
our producer and director thank you very
much we love you very much Ron and no
cut no cut no thumbs-up very much thank
you and also support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in
support them in your communities help
them grow help them stay afloat
simulations links are below we need your
help as well join us and help us grow
and scale and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world achieve that divine
success that you set yourself on we love
you very much thank you and we will see
you soon peace
[Music]